okay and here it's like um you know my
wardrobe Chuck guy runs a drag bar is
running the pink coloring this one this
one this one is he you feed bling-bling
he married his husband in America six
years ago I've had a sexy like but it's
not like nudie but while the
relationship is legally recognized in
the US here in Thailand
it isn't IDEO if we are like marriage
couple but in Thailand your friends
nothing more than that just frame so no
legal right no Canada person no but a
proposed new civil partnership law could
change that I think it's a step in the
right direction you know it's a positive
move and you know a lot of the things
that we get true this are things that
are important to to Emily so I think
obviously we'd like to have full
marriage but I think this is pretty
possible
[Music]
colin has an image of being LGBT
friendly but there is actually a gap in
rights and if they passed this same-sex
civil partnership laws this month it
will be the first Southeast Asian
country to do so and that will give
couple rewrites in terms of things like
property and inheritance but it will
still only be heterosexual couples
campaigners say the law has been watered
down by conservatives they say this
isn't equal rights straight couples will
still have more benefits there is no
right to adoption for LGBTI couple if
they pass the law because society and
government believe that we are not ready
to rise to raise a child and the second
concern is right to enjoy social welfare
if the LGBT couple are the government
officers because government doesn't want
to pay to support social welfare for for
arrear people for me I have confidence
in our luck has been drafting the bill
for the government for more than three
years
she believes marriage equality will
follow the right may not be equal and
that at this stage of course it's not
you know we we didn't provide them their
full set of rights like the heterosexual
couple we know that this is our not not
a hundred percent perfect law yet but we
will continue to work on this law this
is the core yeah cambridge city city
hall yeah while ninety seven percent of
ties consulted support the bill its
conservative politicians that get the
final say they need to be convinced now
is the time for thailand to change
shabam robin's Sky News thanks